caring for your garden really strikes at
the five habits of the heart
and it's good to talk about those again
because people associate food with their
lives and you have to care for people's
lives because people's lives are
important caring for the lives of the
community it's also embedded in a larger
goal of social justice and social change
that food justice efforts seek to
address food justice is about actually
providing the foods that are
historically culturally appropriate for
the culture it's Kevin oh I love cabbage
I love yeah that's spicy cabbage my mom
makes it sound like I'm wrong really she
was like chicken broth instead of water
put the cabbage in there they like whole
bunch of red peppers question about the
kind of stuff and just missed the ball
to the board all the way down that's it
but her spicy cabbage cooked down it's
like always like my friends come over
for when I come home like it's really
good so food security is just about
getting food to a community so just
getting nutritious food to a community
that's really what it's about I mean we
have food everywhere I can go back to
the bodega right here on the corner and
get food but then the questions that the
food is not healthy will you see foods
like corn peas squash like Fuji regular
see in the grocery store it's cool to be
able to grow them and then actually and
actually you don't have to force people
to eat foods they don't want to eat like
who's they already see in the grocery
stores because once you show them that
they can grow these kind of foods in
their neighborhoods or where they're
located
then they don't they can still go to the
grocery store but learn about all their
food from the grocery store and the
purpose of community gardens is to
provide a portion of food to communities
it's not gonna supply the entire
community foods until it grows more but
the small space that there is it's an
opportunity to expose people to more
nutritious foods that they grow
themselves
you